كتبت تلك الكلمات العابره ممزوجه
بالحكايات الحافله ساروي لكم قليلا عن
معاناتنا لعلكم تسمعون ندائي ونداء جميع
اطفالنا دعمت موهم بالغالي والرخيص ونحن
لنا الله يا ليتني لم اولد عربيه لان هذا
عار علي اتسك تون امام تلك المجازر عار
عليكم عجزت الكلمات عن هول ترى من اشلاء
اطفال
ونساء قالها الرسول على الفراش امه محمد
وانا لار امه
محمد رحمك الله يا ذاك الاسد من صرخه
امراه فزعت يا ليتني كنت في ذاك العصر ولا
في عصر هؤلاء الجبناء افتخر بابناء شعبنا
لانهم اروا للعالم قيمه هؤلاء الاشرار لو
اجتمعت العالم يدا بيد لما كنا في هذا
المكان نعاني من الجوع والعطش ونقص ونقص
في الاموال والانفس هذا الضمار الهائل
انتم مسؤولون عنه لو لم تدعموه ل لما حدث
كل هذا ونقول لنا الله وحسبنا الله ونعم
[موسيقى]
الوكيل
ا